[Music]  Abigail Spencer dishes on former suits  co-star Megan markle's upcoming royal  wedding to Prince Harry he is very lucky  I think she's doing okay et spoke with  the actress during NBC's summer press  event on Wednesday in Los Angeles where  she had nothing but praise for the  bride-to-be we were born on the same day  hours apart in the same year like we  have it's yeah that's like a whole other  thing is how similar we are I mean she's  a trusted friend and one of the most  glorious people I've ever met and dished  on what she might gift the royal  newlyweds I've known her for years  before the show but um you know I think  what they would love is just to donate  to one of the charities that they are  involved in I mean that's where her  heart is so I think she needs nothing  once for nothing but also would just  love for anybody to pour out their  hearts and their wallets to the  organizations they're involved with  [Music]  [Applause]